just explain what exactly these changes
are going to do well the stalking
protection orders that come into force
tomorrow will enable a force like my in
Sussex Police to help a victim of
stalking almost immediately so at the
moment if you want to get some sort of
form of of injunction against the
stalker you have to apply to court
yourself and go through a very lengthy
process this will allow the police to
apply for that injunction order and it
will stop the perpetrator perhaps from
coming near you're approaching you plus
it will have some positive requirements
attached to it as well so you can
actually make sure that the perpetrator
perhaps goes to a program of help if
there's one available in your area of
course there's been some really
upsetting and troubling cases reported
about you know women who've reported
people for stalking and nothing's
happened and as a result they've gone on
to even lose their lives yeah how
important do you think yeah what the
changes are now well this is a big step
change in the right direction for all of
us unfortunately I too have been and
continued to be a victim of stalking
with a small group of individuals who
seem hell-bent on making my life really
difficult in fact one has a custodial
sentence at the moment that's been
suspended for two years so like like
many victims I really can empathize with
this and I know from my own experience
having to go through the civil courts
just to get an injunction was a terribly
gruesome experience and the civil and
the criminal courts when we originally
applied to those they let me down as
well so I think with these stalking
protection orders this gives the police
the opportunity to intervene on behalf
of the victim if you're a victim of
stalking you often don't even know and
we very often get victims who phone the
police and they say well I'm not sure so
first of all we've now invented an
acronym for fo you are so that the
police can easily identify whether it's
stalking or harassment so if the
behavior is fixated obsessive unwanted
or repeated then the police officer in
the first instance will know that that
stalking stalking
a criminal conviction attached to it now
thanks to the new law that came that's
recently come in and these stalking
protection orders are part of that new
law as well so they will allow the
police officer who's identified stalking
correctly in the first instance to put
an injunction in place to give the
victim some time and respite and then
that also and really importantly for the
victims point of view it says for the
victim I hear you I believe you and
we're going to do something about it
because very often victims by the time
they report to the police they've been
subjected to over a hundred incidents of
stalking now if one of those only
happens every week that's nearly two
years worth so that intense heightened
stative of alarm that a victim will go
through I cannot underestimate it's no
wonder they come to us with
post-traumatic stress disorder and worse
so these protection orders massively
important and we welcome in Sussex and
I'm hoping that in Sussex in my force
here tomorrow we will be one of the
first in the country to actually issue a
couple of these stalking protection
orders you know I can't help wondering
if stalking is one of those things that
we've been a bit slow as a society to
really appreciate what an impact it has
on people who are the victims of it you
were saying there but your own sort of
lived experience of what happened can
you describe to our viewers about what
it feels like to be a victim of stalking
well first you don't realize what's
happening for me because I'm a public
figure
you kind of expect a lot of noise anyway
around you you know you're not
everybody's best friend and people tend
to be quite vocal against you but this
particular individual was a relentless I
mean he was fixated he was obsessive he
emailed lots of people he went across
social media he printed stuff about me
calling me a pedophile a prostitute I
was accused of murder of child sex abuse
you name it and he then professionally
tried to attack me by contacting
professional boards that I sit on and
people I work with and it was just
relentless and there were pages and
pages across social media he was then
able to connect with others of a similar
ilk in my County so there's four of them
now
and one of them I'm in court with next
month and and this has been going on for
nearly eight years so as a you know as a
victim and I'm I'm one of the the
luckier ones because some of the victims
I meet have just had the most awful
experiences people they're their
perpetrators have been put in prison and
they know they're coming out soon and
they're terrified for their lives I had
one woman held my hands and she said
he's coming out next year Katie I know
he's going to kill me you've got to help
me
so you're absolutely right this is an
invidious crime and I think what we're
seeing is just the tip of the iceberg
because by as I said by the time a
victim comes forwards they often don't
know they're being stalked they don't
understand the difference and the
difference is really important because
that will determine what response the
police give so if the police correctly
identify stalking in the first instance
they will then go down the proper route
to gather the intelligence and build the
case file that they need to prosecute
that individual if they don't recognize
it then the victim doesn't get supported
and doesn't get help and this is why
these protection orders are so vital
they are a step in the right direction
but there is one thing police forces
need to do across the country we need to
make sure that not just the police but
all our criminal justice partners
understand that if those orders are
breached there is a consistent response
to that breach and that person is then
dealt with effectively because at the
moment as the inspection that I carried
out last year I commissioned her
Majesty's Inspectorate to do an
inspection of Sussex Police and their
response to the stalking and they made
local recommendations for us but they
made some really important ones
nationally for policing and one of the
things that they really discovered was
that the police are not doing proper
risk assessments on victims in that
first instance so we're trying a pilot
here in Sussex with Surrey and Cheshire
Police at the moment looking at a new
risk assessment for victims we found
they got one if they were in a domestic
abuse situation but a third of our
victims aren't they could be stalked by
someone who's a stranger okay.thank they
don't get that risk assessment then
thank you so much for talking so
powerfully about this important story
and also sharing your own experience
thank you as well while we've got you
and
it was reported this week that Boris
Johnson's planned to review the role of
police and crime commissioners like
myself do you think the Prime Minister's
committed to keeping you in yes
absolutely and we welcome this review
and I and my colleagues earlier this
week we had a general meeting and the
policing minister came and the Cabinet
Secretary was there and we asked them
both about the review and they said
actually they're doing a review across
all government departments and we
welcome this review because they're also
looking at potentially how they might
expand our role into the criminal
justice system so give us potentially
further responsibilities